it's not very hard to reverse engineer a
business what's hard is the process and
for us a lot of us as entrepreneurs
you're competing with yourself the
amount of energy entrepreneurs put into
the people they compete with is one of
my most interesting things that I spend
time on there is nobody that is taking
your growth away from you you do not
have one competitor because the world is
not a zero-sum game the the thing that's
holding people back from building a
bigger businesses themselves because if
you're spending six hours a day worried
about your competitor well they've
already accomplished their goal if you
spend zero you now have allocated all
your time to building what you want to
build